-Hi, Kaitlyn!
-Hello, Jimmy!
-Nice to meet you over Zoom.
-I know.
It's so nice to meet you.
This is so cool.
This is so cool for me.
I've been a huge fan of yours
for a long time.
So this is insane.
-This is rad.
I'm a fan of yours as well.
I know you're busy prepping for
the film version of
"Dear Evan Hansen."
-I can't even tell you, Jimmy.
I literally cannot describe
to you how excited I am.
I think I've only had like
three musical auditions
in my whole life, and
"Evan Hansen" was one of them.
So it feels insane that I'm
going to be a part of that.
I've always wanted to
do a musical.
-How did the other
two auditions go?
Not so good?
-Well, not so good,
but they were okay.
-I had the worst audition ever
in the history of the business.
I auditioned to be on Broadway
to be Frankenstein.
-On Broadway?
-Dude, it was --
I'll never forget it.
Honestly I'm getting --
I'm about to vomit right now
because I remember going to
an apartment -- I'm not going to
say the casting dir--
you know, who was casting me,
but the piano player was there,
and I go, "I'm just going to
sing 'Puttin' on the Ritz.'"
I go, "Yeah, I can do it."
♪ If you're blue and you ♪
I go, "Got it."
I get there. They go, "Yeah, we
don't want to hear that song.
We want to hear this new song."
I'm like,
"Oh, here's where I get busted
because I'm not
a real actor or a singer."
And it was so bad.
Everyone felt so bad
in the room. It was awful.
And I remember, I was
so embarrassed when I went home.
It was cold.
It was like December,
and there was steam
coming off of my body.
[ Laughs ]
That's how embarrassed I was.
It's like a block of --
-[ Laughs ]
My other musical audition,
that's exactly the same thing
that happened to me.
They're like, "Oh, yeah, no,
you're singing in the wrong key.
It's actually several keys
higher than what
you have come in to sing."
So it was like, "Oh, great,
I don't have that prepared."
-Well, I mean, you're in a band
with your sister Mady.
And you're called --
Is it Beulahbelle?
-Yes.
-You just released
a new song, "Being You."
I just heard it. It's awesome.
Congrats on that.
-Thanks, Jimmy.
-But that wasn't your first band
with your sister apparently.
-It was not.
-Yeah.
-We used to be called Hot Pink,
which I think is a great name,
and I don't know
why we changed it.
-This is bizarre, but we
actually talked to some people
and we actually
got some unseen footage
from an early performance
of yours.
This is -- Check out you on
guitar. This is pretty awesome.
♪♪
Oh, my gosh.
-Oh, my gosh!
-The commitment I had to -- I
think I remember telling myself,
"I need to get down on my knees
and really get into it,"
and then I quickly got up.
I was not down on the ground.
[ Laughing ] I got up so fast.
-You rocked. That is one
of the coolest things.
Hey, I want to talk
about your projects
because you have so many
besides "Dear Evan Hansen."
You have a movie out now
on HBO and HBO Max
called "Coastal Elites."
How did you get
involved with that?
-I got a call from Jay Roach,
who's the director,
and sent me the script,
and he asked me
to play the role of the nurse.
So, there's five separate
monologues of all of
these different characters
sort of, like, talking about
their frustration about
the current state of the world,
and he asked me to be in it
with Bette and Dan Levy
and Sarah Paulson and Issa,
and I was just sort of like,
"Are you sure?
This is a lot of pressure."
But it was really incredible
to be able to shoot something
in quarantine. It was wild.
-It's really a cool thing
to watch. It's great.
You also have a new series
on Hulu called "Monsterland."
It premieres tomorrow.
How would you describe this one?
-Yeah, "Monsterland" sort of
follows several characters
that are -- we follow sort of
these broken and troubled people
who are forced to sort of
cope with the darkest parts
of themselves, and I play
a young girl named Toni
who is a mother
to a 4-year-old girl.
And she is also trying to
cope with just, you know --
my character is
just trying to cope with
her inner monster as well,
and it was the first time I have
ever played a mom in my life.
And it was also the first time
I did a Cajun French accent,
which is as difficult
as it sounds.
-Yeah.
-Well, you knocked it out of
the park. I want to show a clip.
Here's Kaitlyn Dever
in "Monsterland."
Take a look at this.
-My name is Alex.
-Where you from, Alex?
-Uh, nearby.
-You lyin' already.
-Why do you assume
that I'm lying?
-Cause you ain't talkin' flat.
Folks around here sound like
they filed the letter G
from the damn alphabet.
-I'm here doing a job.
-Offshore?
-Mm-hmm.
-Then you better heal up
and get a straight story
'cause trouble
don't make pay date.
-Well...
I'm no trouble.
-Yeah,
and I'm the Queen of Sheba.
-My thanks to Kaitlyn Dever.
"Coastal Elites" is
on HBO and HBO Max now.
And "Monsterland" premieres
on Hulu tomorrow.
Thank you so much again
for coming on, Kaitlyn.
I appreciate it.
-Thank you, Jimmy.
Thanks for having me.
This was awesome.